the last year was a great one for apple
and people that are fans of Apple
products but that doesn't mean that they
didn't release some flops now in this
video I'm going to cover the best and
the worst Apple products I'm not going
to cover everything that they released
but there are some really stand out ones
and the first one has got to be the
iPhone 15s starting with the regular
ones now for many years regular iPhones
were not great compared to the pros but
this year they knocked it out of the
park of course we got USB type-c finally
thank you apple and thank you EU and
that's a great update but with that we
had the rounded design on the corners
which was nice and the back becoming
frosted so you don't have all those
fingerprints all over it but what really
impressed was the changes on the front
and on the inside we got the dynamic
island in the regular iPhones and that
is really nice not only visual but what
it does and what surprised me is the
fact that Apple put in their super
bright xdr display in there matching
with the pro phones of course we got a
chip update and with that the real world
battery life was really improved even
though they didn't mention it on their
website that was really nice topc
especially with the 15 plus model that
thing has the best battery life in an
iPhone ever and beats out practically
every Android phone as well and then we
had other minor updates like the
cellular connectivity got better as well
the plus one has the same speakers as
the pro Max model so if you want to buy
a new iPhone this is a great time now of
course we got the iPhone 15 Pros as well
those are also really good we got 3
nanometer chips beating out every other
manufacturer apple is the first we got
titanium which I'm a little iffy on but
they are lighter a little bit slimmer
and that was great and the cameras had
some nice updates a lot of good software
features but with the pro Max the 5x
lens proved to be much better than I
expected I love the shots that I get
with that thing and it even beat out
some 10x lenses surprisingly in some
situation so this is the best overall
camera phone uh that you can get now
with that we have these bad boys right
here I have to men mention them because
with the USB type-c iPhones we have USB
type-c earpods and these are incredible
they're only 19 bucks I made a full
video on them and they actually have
lossless support so you can plug them
right in and get incredible quality and
these actually sound better than airpods
3 so for 19 bucks you might as well pick
up a set just in case to have or if you
want to use them wired in certain
situations they work with other devices
as well like Android phones and
different laptops they are a steal now
along with that we have the 15-in
MacBook Air this is one of my favorite
MacBooks now it does have the same M2
Chip and so that's a little older and
still the same slow Bas ssds that are in
that machine that kind of sucks as well
but for most people this is the best
MacBook to buy it's incredibly thin and
for the size it's really lightweight
weight and apple priced it at
$12.99 which is lower than what we
expected now in the past decade or even
more you'd have to spend $4 $2,500 if
you wanted a large screen Mac but now
you don't and the performance is more
than good enough for most people so I
love this machine and I highly highly
recommend it and the crazy thing is you
can buy it discounted right now for an
even better price now the next winner in
in my opinion is the Apple Watch series
9 now it does have the same design we
don't have much change but with that it
got the new S9 chip which is finally a
new chip that is a lot more efficient
the past two three generations they
actually had the same chip that they
would just slightly change in rename but
with this one we actually get much
better battery life it is a really big
real world difference and I bought one
for my son and it lasts him twice as
long as his large SE with that we have
the display that's also 2,000 nits now
and that is nice to have now the series
10 is going to get a major overhaul so
if you can wait you might want to do
that but if you want a great Apple watch
you can pick one up right now before
they might get reann again the next one
is the M3 Pro and M3 Max MacBooks these
recently came out and some of the specs
were actually downgrades and we did have
some price increases depending depending
on which one you get they segmented the
chips even more so to force you to spend
more money because now if you want the
best performance for CPU you have to get
a Max chip but these had major real
world performance updates much better
than going from the M1 to the M2 and
they do such a great job now the new
black color is also really nice I
absolutely love it so if you've been
waiting to get a higher MacBook or if
you have an M1 Pro or Max and you've
been thinking about updating it is
excellent with its 3 NM design and other
new updates now those are my positives
for this year the real standout products
but now let's get into the negatives the
first one is the Apple watch Ultra 2 now
I am wearing it I do have it but it is
kind of a loser because it is almost the
same it doesn't even say Apple watch
Ultra 2 on there they didn't even go
that far now we did get 3,000 nits of
peak brightness but honestly that
doesn't matter and it does have the
newer chip but the battery life was
already so good it also didn't matter so
if there's one apple was to skip it
would be this one and I almost returned
it and just kept my original but I ended
up passing that on to somebody else it
would have been a lot better if we did
get the rumored black color at least
that would have been an update but it's
not great and with that I have to say
these fine woven cases suck they got rid
of the genuine leather and I bought a
couple of these and as you guys could
see I'm not even using them box is still
hard to open here people are reporting a
lot of scratches even shortly after they
got it uh it just doesn't feel premium
doesn't feel nice I think they could
have done a much better job but
thankfully we have great Alternatives
that are available on the market the
next stud might be controversial but it
is the home pod Apple discontinued the
original one because of bad sales but
then they re-released a slightly worse
version
and it was only $50 less than the
original one which was constantly
discounted to that price anyways now I
could see it make more sense if they
price one at $199 but at $299 it's still
a hard sell for a lot of people compared
to the Alternatives now I do have one
still I do like it but it is not as good
as the original and still a niche
product next we have the M2 Pro n Max
laptops those did come out within the
same year nine months before the M3
versions they had barely any improvement
over the M1 Max basically just an
overclocked M1 Pro and M1 Max chip and
um it just was not worth it I kind of
wish that Apple waited and just released
the M3 versions anyways instead of
getting people to buy them and then
seeing how much better the M3s are now
with that we also got the M2 Pro and M2
Mac Minis and they were pretty good and
they still are as long as you don't
upgrade them much because if you do they
become a worse value and have worse
performance performance at the same time
than just buying a Mac Studio and the
next one is the Mac Pro this is a series
dead in my opinion because it's still
cost the same $6,000 base price even
though it cost Apple a lot less than
before we had very high expectations a
lot of great info that was going to come
out with these but they ended up still
only having an M2 Ultra not an M2
extreme chip or some other name and that
chip is available in the Mac Studio we
also have no external Graphics support
even though technically Apple could do
it if they wanted to for programs that
could leverage multiple graphics and be
worth it and the PCI Express 4 bandwidth
is also limited because it just has one
bust that kind of switches still has the
insane crazy Overkill power supply that
they used to only need for the Intel
chips so they didn't even try to
redesign it they just said what's the
minimum we could do to finally replace
Intel and that is what they did now with
that we have the Mac Studio now this
thing is kind of riding the line here
because compared to the Mac Pro it is a
much better value you can get same
performance to for two grand less as
long as you don't need those limited
internal PCI slots the M2 Ultra is a
fast chip mostly because it fixs the
bottleneck issues of the M1 Ultra but
now that we have the M3 Max for the same
$4,000 it almost matches it in most
cases and some it actually beats it out
but you also get a display a keyboard a
trackpad you get speakers and batteries
included it's portable and that just
makes that machine be not that great of
a value anymore uh especially the with
these coming out just 4 months after and
it makes it a hard sell because you
might as well try to wait for the M3
chip versions of the Mac Studio so
unless you really need extra Thunderbolt
ports and you don't want to use a hub
like I do it is kind of riding the line
there between good and bad and the last
dud is something that I did not expect
when they announced it and it is the new
14in M3 MacBook Pro now it seemed like a
great deal because we can finally get a
14-in at a lower price point but they
got rid of one Thunder P Port there it
supports only one display and the worst
of all they gave it 8 gigs of RAM when
we're basically in
2024 and 8 gigs does slow it down
dramatically in the real world compared
to 16 gigs even with nothing open but
one program now we made a real world
multitasking comparison video for you
guys to check out and the difference is
drastic and I think the craziest thing
is if you walk into a store or you order
online for a model that's in stock and
ships quickly you cannot get 16 gigs you
have to custom order it it'll take a
week to a week and a half just to ship
out and that means that people are kind
of forced into buying a machine that is
drastically bottlenecked or they have to
spend more money on an M3 Pro which is
probably what Apple wants you to do so
it wouldn't cost them much to give it 12
gigs at least base or better yet 16 RAM
prices are very very low right now but
they did not do it so even though we
have a more affordable machine in
reality it is probably the worst dollu
MacBook in my opinion that you can buy
because if you spend just a little bit
more you get way better performance with
the M3 Pro which is a real winner so
there's some other Apple products that
were released that I didn't think were
as kind of not noteworthy to mention you
guys let me know your thoughts down in
the comment section below and let me
know which Apple product that you got
that you absolutely love within the last
year go ahead and click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those great videos right over there this
has been Max and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
video